today the community remembering a young
man's life 16-year-old liam gilligly was
hit and killed by a car this weekend
police say he was crossing during a do
not walk signal at the intersection of
centennial center and tropical parkway
as kate houston reports some think this
could have been prevented
kind of a brother figure
he's a great guy andrew pickup is one of
many centennial high school students
grieving the loss of liam gilligly
friends called him google the school's
doing it well like in room 200 we have
this like um
they brought in a bunch of counselors to
help us and i went to it earlier and
just like hug hugged it out kind of
thing felt nice
according to classmates and parents liam
was at centennial in tropical helping
his jrotc group collect money i said to
him i go
this is scaring me this is an accident
waiting to happen kim crisp lives in the
area and saw students on the median and
running into traffic to collect money
from cars just excited with somebody
who's going to give us a donation you
know and then they go between three
lanes and walk up and down the lanes to
get the donation and it's not worth it
chris kids did rotc while in school and
says they never had them so close to
traffic while doing fundraisers she
hopes the school changes their
guidelines for the safety of the kids
any single person who probably gave them
money saturday would probably have
written a check or something and said
here if you need money we don't ever
want this to happen again
kate houston live local now
now we reached out to the clark county
school district for more information on
its safety guidelines for fundraising we
have not at this time gotten a response